this is a new world review and I'm your
host Grand Line waifu i have been
threatening to steal your soul and
replace it with a beanie for so long
that maybe we forget i can be happy and
kind and maybe replace your soul with
insert nice thing here instead use those
like and dislike buttons and maybe just
this time things won't be dark and
dangerous maybe i won't crawl out from
under your bed with a creepy dog wearing
a beanie instead i'll walk out of your
mirror with a freshly baked pie
who doesn't like their soul stolen by a
pie bearing harpie they can't get away
from because they can't move several
tons of door speaking of several tons of
door let's discuss episodes 23 and 24 of
Hunter hunter episode 23 this was a
clever episode it started out very light
very funny very much on par with what
we've seen in the past while
acknowledging that hey things were going
to get darker our heroes got a training
montage we saw everyone level up after
the first part of the hunter exam in
terms of emotional balance the episode
was very well constructed the silliness
of lay audio finding out that the
bathroom door was weighted was a great
addition and as the team work led to
fruitful results it's interesting to
note that so Todd says comment about
God's arm being stronger than ever when
it recovered was definitely true either
that or we're going to see God and
struggle with drawing a bow or something
in an episode or two to the end of the
episode the southern darkness is in and
of itself good the abruptness of the
behavior the finality of it the
mechanical response the angles they took
in the art were all beautiful this is an
awkward situation isn't it I guess
before I get started we should be clear
about something the ground line waifu
cartoon image is brown and you've seen
in photos here here and here that I'm a
black woman so I'm going to buy a
necessity need to spend some time
talking about exactly what happened at
the end of episode 23 and the level of
trauma I experienced seeing someone who
looks like me
essentially shot in the head here's the
thing that we need to remember i watch
episodes one by one a review one episode
before moving on to the next even within
the episodes of this review series
whether this woman has been killed or
disabled for the moment i don't know at
time of writing the review because i
write before i talk to you about it i
don't know what happened to her and I'm
not going to blunt my response to make
it more palatable because frankly people
like me also watch anime people younger
than me who look like me and have
similar experiences to me watch anime
that's important representation matters
and it's because representation matters
more than people realize that this
character is incredibly significant in
more ways than I can count I know for a
fact that this particular episode review
is likely to upset some people but the
point of a review is to give my honest
responses and opinions and if this is
where I draw the line what's the point
of reviewing so why did they
functionally kill the first black woman
of the series the first black femme
character my immediate response the
character on meeting her was she's
badass amazing empathetic beautiful
suave looking finding out she was
someone kill what Trust was a huge red
flag but I should have recognized but to
be honest I was blindsided by the fact
that if all the cosplays I've seen if
this show this character who I don't
even know the name of is one that I've
seen that I could identify with I looked
at her and thought oh she looks like me
I really appreciate that they've put in
a character like her and that she
doesn't seem to have huge flaws that
narratively would stem from her racial
background it's nice to see someone who
looks like me it's nice to see a femme
in the show it's nice to see if them in
the show who hasn't been hyper feminized
but of course those things are all red
flags in this show that I've already
discussed if someone femme doesn't look
hyper femme if they're not there to be
ogled sexualized fetishized or
brutalized it doesn't seem they can be
there at all simply put there are things
wrong with this series and the treatment
of black people in the treatment of
women are two of them I'm breaking my
own rule of getting up on a soapbox and
I know that but the effect of this
episode had on me was extreme and needed
contextualizing because on the one hand
I fully understood why it happened
narrative Lee and on the other I hated
that it had to happen to the first black
woman we see in the series the worst
part about it is that I don't see it as
particularly dark
it's possible to tell a dark story
without engaging racist and sexist
tropes I should know I write and play in
dark stories on almost a daily basis and
I know people will say well gee l-dub
what do you want do you want us not to
have any black people in shows at all
with that make you happy and the answer
to that is of course not why not instead
have more people of color appear on
screen in the first place so that this
particular scene doesn't look like a
racially based decision because maybe it
wasn't and I get that but that's what it
looked and felt like and the next
response I expect is this is anime and
it's set in a place like Japan the
demographic is largely Asian but is it
look at the range of pale skinned people
and how they're drawn look at the lack
of brown people think about the styles
of music we've had the cultural elements
that have been brought into this show
the flamenco the chairs
those are very western-style elements
and yes I'm aware that this series is
almost 25 years old the culture then was
very different to the culture now I'm
also aware that if I binge the show I'd
probably have a different experience of
it but as I've said before I review this
way because it's the way that I can get
the purest response to each individual
episode when it originally aired it
would have been a weekly event this is
my reaction to that weekly experience
and if I were an eight-year-old GL dub
watching this when it aired I'd have had
this same response in 1998 spread out
over a week until the next episode so I
think all these feelings are valid and
relevant but for the sake of those of
you hanging in there I'm going to let go
of it for now as a final note on this
episode it's heartbreaking to me that
kilwa doesn't believe he had a friend in
the world whoever she is or was she's
most definitely a friend to him too for
him to be able to even mention he made a
friend in such a hostile environment
says everything about her character and
I hope we see her again cautiously odd
into episode 24 canary of course
survives I was somewhat aware that she
would though I wasn't sure how Canaries
an important character for many reasons
and that import carries through this
episode too as suspected she is one of
the only characters to be friends with
Kilwa though there's an interesting
distinction to be made between those who
act as though they're friends with
Kiawah and those he sees as friends
notably Lee audio and karateka don't see
Kilwa as their friend rather they see
GaN as a friend and therefore what to
help GaN help his friend canary sees
killer as a friend even if he doesn't
see her as worthy of him the poignant
thing here is that the first time Kilwa
asks her to be his friend she declines
because she knows his mother is watching
given Kiowas heightened awareness of
those around him it seems absurd to
believe that canary saw his mother
hiding in the bushes while kylo I didn't
so we have to assume that kylo I pulled
her lame for not standing up to his
family and being her friend regardless
the way GaN does as a result she throws
caution to the wind and calls for help
for her friend is it a consequence of
believing she disappointed Kela killer
has no way of knowing this situation
occurred he has no way of hearing of
Canaries care of him or seeing her eyes
soften or any of the things gone sees in
questions it makes for a lot of
interesting watching and it makes her
fascinating on another scale this girl
with definite martial abilities who has
a great deal of training that makes her
seemingly as capable as Kiowa and the
others is an apprentice Butler for
assassins
how does she wreck
Syal that how did she get hired she's
definitely capable and intelligent but
assassins surely this family of
sociopaths understand that the capacity
for empathy and care is a serious issue
when it comes to protection that it's
exploitable regardless gone and Kilwa
have a very clever way of getting under
the skins of anyone with a capacity for
emotion and that reaction is not lost on
me nor should it be lost on you at this
point people see the children is naive
and ignorant
neither is and both are very blatantly
shown not to be shut up dog no you shut
up you sure I'm not talking to myself
neither is and both are very blatantly
shown not to be kilowatt allowing murder
QED Kilwa allowing me to ki are we going
into a Dragon Ball style
naming convention here anyway killer
allowing me rocky to whip him ripped
mute anyway you are allowing me rocky to
whip him as an apology for stabbing him
is a fascinating way to do things it
acknowledges that me rocky has emotional
needs it acknowledges me Rocky's desire
to harm and it also acknowledges the
social expectations of the house he
hands himself to his abused and abusive
mother as payment for what his family
perceive as wrongdoing but just as
easily just leaves we see this helpless
kid being abused but by this point we
knows who've just wait to see his eyes
like gone we know to just let it happen
this in essence is killaz
personal final phase of the exam
speaking of abuse let's discuss kil waz
mother and sister for a moment she seems
to care so much for him but only in a
strange and twisted way the fact that
she was stabbed has been a story point
since Kilwa first described his family
seeing her fully interacting with him
and his friends gives us a really clear
insight into the world Kilwa was raised
in even though it doesn't give us a
particular understanding of why he
stabbed her behaviors that happen in
their family streaming a boy up by his
arms and whipping him till he bleeds is
an awful family practice but one that
Kiowa and the rest of his family seemed
to think his commonplace and expected it
seems odd to think that his mother would
truly believe that she has him under her
control physically she knows his
skillset for the most part and even if
she didn't before he left whether she's
an assassin herself or not she lives
around them and knows the techniques he
could employ it remains to be seen
whether the bandages and the technology
she wears on her head are due to the
damage Kilwa inflicted I suspect they
are
the lack of oddity and how they carry
themselves show that Kilwa is used to
the side of his family who can blame a
boy for stabbing a woman who's all too
happy to have him strung up in a dungeon
and whipped by his brother and to be
sure those eyes scare his mother they
please his father and they fascinate me
because they soften when they see gone
there's something very concerning about
Gon and Killua together in a way that is
less concerning for GaN kylo and canary
I'm kind of interested in the idea of
maybe gone and kill while wearing some
Chippendale outfits not Chippendale
tails I'd love to see them in tales that
is a tangent that is unnecessary anyway
it'll be exciting when karappa colognes
about where Canaries from since you
mentioned that the wasteland she was
raised in was the birthplace of the
Phantom troupe those shadowy figures
caught up because up pretty highs go all
red for the fact that there is such a
link there is a hefty not've by the way
this is the next place we're going on
the ride so be prepared it was only
briefly mentioned and briefly called -
and the idea that this young sweet
dangerous new character may have learned
her skills from and be involved with the
crew karateka has dedicated his life to
hunting down is an enjoyable one it says
a lot that one of the most emotionally
normative people we've come across so
far has a direct tire to those who
committed such atrocities the fact that
she throws away the reference interest
me more it's basically a bookmark saying
don't worry about it we're going to make
mention of it later and we're going to
visit this wasteland
she told Kilwa she would show him around
when he went perhaps it's time for them
to go now that kill was free to do what
he wants until he becomes the white
tiger assassin Lord his father dreams he
will be and so are you go be that white
tiger assassin Lord of your dreams
because that's it for me
if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produces in general
like share subscribe and comment to tell
me how much you love
Hisoka even though he wasn't in this
episode at all finally please comment
with your thoughts on episodes 23 and 24
of Hunter hunter this has been the new
world review and I'll see you next time